sie schaffen für uns täglich waren quer
durchs land netzen von kunde zu kunde
stecken im stau und schlafen auf
überfüllten rastplätzen
reinfried und wie wir teilen dieses leid
aber auch diese leidenschaft sie sind
trucker auf der a2 wirklich nur noch
krieg das ist der blanke wahnsinn was
hier abgeht unfälle baustellen und
vollgestopfte parkplätze bestimmen ihren
alltag
die nerven liegen oft plant man darf 60
fragen die warum muss ich auf 50 bremsen
versteht nicht
ein knochenjob der einiges verlangt
das privatleben bleibt auf der strecke
[Musik]
wenn ich sowas sehe der mann vielleicht
doch schon gerne auch dabei
die trucker leben auf der autobahn
[Musik]
dance laden gehört für trucker wie piet
fast überall zum job dazu nur erfahren
ist nicht mehr
kind nimmt die körperliche anstrengung
mit humor
[Musik]
hin und wieder ein bisschen
krafttraining ist doch eine feine sache
kaputt gehen darf nicht wir sind jetzt
solarmodule wenn also diese mit
sicherheit kostbar
da wollte man schon mit vorsichtig sein
ja warum
seit 19 jahren fährt peter bergen lkw
für ein leben auf der autobahn gab er
seinen erlernten beruf als koch auf
hinterm steuer seines 40-tonners fühlt
er sich wohl
auch wenn er auf den unmut der menschen
zu spüren bekommt der nation es im
großen und ganzen pkw-fahrer regen sich
alle tierisch über uns auf das wir vor
der krise und die straßen blockieren
aber gut wenn er bei aldi die regale
leer bleiben würden höhere was dann
können sie vielleicht warum denken für
das trucker leben muss man geboren sein
den berühmten diesel im blut haben
[Musik]
wenn man das einmal nur des geldes wegen
macht dann hat man in diesem job
eigentlich nichts zu suchen
also ich habe schon einige kinder lernen
die dazu sagen wieder aufgegeben haben
wir haben dann einfach keine
vorstellungen davon was wirklich abgeht
auf deutschen straßen und autobahnen
reinfried kampe genannte sie hat alles
miterlebt er ist seit 30 jahren
lkw-fahrer war gefühlt in jedem letzten
winkel der nation
trotzdem birgt der job immer wieder
unvorhersehbares
an den end ladestationen ist er abhängig
vom personal vor ort
dort gibt es schon mal böse
überraschungen der katzen wissen wie
schnell das geht weil die machen stumpf
erst um 6 uhr machen die die schranke
auf dann dürfen paare auf waren als die
schranke wieder zu
die erstmal und aber noch ganz bestimmte
zeit nur wenn die mittagspause machen
wir mittags pro werk was mich am meisten
ärgert es dass sie zu wie kaffee trinken
die sie fährt einen der größten
er transportiert so ziemlich alles was
auf seinen 13 meter langen auflieger
passt heute ist es eine tonnenschwere
stanzmaschine
in osterholz scharmbeck bei bremen wird
geladen dann muss die fracht an die
niederländische grenze gebracht werden
[Applaus]
passt das ist auch schon erwartet das
hat auch schon mal war sie hat glück bei
vielen kunden ist er mit der ware sich
selbst überlassen
in diesem fall übernimmt ein
professionelles team für
schwerlasttransporte das beladen
trotzdem ist er für die ladungssicherung
mitverantwortlich
wenn die nicht gesichert ist und ich
steige reisen dann habe ich das ding bei
mir vorne und für aus essen
diese drei tonnen in bewegung kommen die
maschinen dadurch wenn ich richtig in
algier nicht auszumalen welche folgen
eine vollbremsung haben könnte
sie hat es nun eilig
er nimmt die bundesstraße denn die a1
bei bremen ist täglich verstopft hier
geht es flüssig voran
wären da nicht die übervorsichtigen
verkehrsteilnehmer die sich von einer
radarfalle abschrecken lassen
auch ein alter haudegen ist da mal
genervt
da vorne ist ein blitzer man darf 60
fahren hier warum muss ich auf 50
bremsen versteht nicht
schnell aber sicher so lautet die devise
in ordnung bei den ganzen
sicherheitssystem meinetwegen können
noch viel mehr einbauen
hier kann so jetzt mit dem tempomat
nichts passieren sobald vorne weil wir
vorne gebremst wird und auch richtig
gebremst wird bremst der auch der geht
wirklich bis 0 in die knie
er bleibt stehen nach viereinhalb
stunden fahrzeit muss sie eine pause
machen
die kurze zeit nutzte er um den kontakt
zu seinen beiden erwachsenen kindern zu
halten
[Musik]
ich habe da ein kleines problem
christoph hätte die mutter arbeite kann
ich noch aber wahrscheinlich meine
arbeit war das woche danach also nichts
das ist so lächerlich kleine botschaft
vom gehen wir wo wir zusammen tag machen
wollten
machen wir am wochenende später das halt
eben wir wollen sollten zusammen angehen
dass wir haben so ein förder sonntag
wollen wir eigentlich zwei dreimal im
jahr machen letztes jahr ist noch einmal
geworden
aus zeitmangel weil er im kühl und ein
halber als kühllaster fährt und dann ist
auch so das sind unsere jobs das was wir
beide und dann muss man eben uns darauf
einstellen waren an der müritz in
mecklenburg vorpommern wie wir in
blumenthal verbringt in der wohnung
ihrer eltern die letzten stunden des
wochenendes mit ihrem sohn livio
die 30 jährige ist seit einem jahr zwar
in
noch heute am sonntag beginnt ihre
arbeitswoche am nachmittag heißt es
abschied nehmen
ja die sonntage sind immer so ein
bisschen schwierig auf der einen seite
freue ich mich natürlich dass es wieder
losgeht
auf der anderen seite ist es natürlich
auch schwer für mich den kleinen auch
wieder alleine zu lassen
man ist halt doch schon traurig lange
gerade wenn er sagt man soll nicht
weggehen ist das immer schon ein
bisschen herzzerreißend auf jeden fall
während libyen mit ihrem lkw unterwegs
ist wird niveau von seinem papa und
vivien eltern umsorgt
die drei wäre das gar nicht mag ich dass
ich das so machen kann um meinen traum
leben kann
da bin ich schon sehr sehr dankbar nach
einer krankheit musste wie wir in ihrer
arbeit als krankenschwester aufgeben
2017 machte sie ihren lkw führerschein
natürlich bin ich stolz und wenn mich
einer fragt was macht meine frau meine
tochter
ja ja sag ich die fährten und 40 tonnen
und da kommt was ferdinand verzichten
doch bevor vivien zur arbeit beginnen
kann muss sie von waren zu ihrer
spedition ins westfälische sassenberg
mit dem auto fahren
habe ich einen kilometer ungefähr vor
mir damit ich meine eltern mir ein
bisschen einräumen
dann lege ich mich nur eins zwei drei
stunden je nach dem ja und dann geht es
auch schon wieder los oft tue werde ich
zum laden fand und lass ich mal
überraschen muss dann geht für pete geht
es von ost nach west auf einer der
transitstrecken in deutschland der a2
einer autobahn mit schlechtem ruf
die a2 ist die schlimmste autobahn
deutschlands
die autobahn ist komplett von berlin bis
runter bis dortmund ausgebaut dreispurig
und trotzdem gibt es hier so viele
unfälle und tote das ist einfach
unfassbar und unbegreiflich meiner
meinung nach so gut wie nicht mehr
angucke die polnischen kollegen zum
beispiel was sie fahren in warschau los
und dann nonstop bis hierhin und dann
ist hier irgendwann ist mal möglichkeit
angesagt und dann rappelt das dann haben
sie die sicherheitssysteme daran gespart
die moderne lkw eigentlich haben sollte
aber die sind ja noch nicht pflicht und
dann rappelt das und gibt viele tote
also es ist hier auf der a2 wirklich nur
noch krieg das ist der blanke wahnsinn
was hier abgeht
die a2 gilt seit jahren als
unfallschwerpunkt allein in
niedersachsen gab es 2017 auf dieser
strecke 3538 unfälle bis zu 130.000
fahrzeuge täglich darunter ein drittel
lastwagen rollen über die route von
berlin richtung ruhrgebiet die
spezialisierte verfügungseinheit der
hannoveraner polizei versucht mit
maßnahmen wie abstands kontrollen die
gefahren einzudämmen
ganz gefährliche autobahn mit vielen
unfällen auch viele tödliche unfälle und
da ist abstand ein ganz ganz großes
problem und da sind halt auch die
osteuropäer mit drei beteiligten
deswegen versuchen wir das zu
sensibilisieren mit solchen kontrollen
deutsche lkw fahrer bekommen ihren
strafzettel auf dem postweg bei
ausländischen trucks verfahren die
beamten anders die fahrer müssen die
strafe sofort bezahlen
[Musik]
neben der abstandskontrolle untersuchen
die polizisten auch immer die ruhe und
lenkzeiten sowie
geschwindigkeitsverstöße die auf dem
fahrtenschreiber der lkw aufgezeichnet
werden
jeder gefahrenen meter wird überwacht
die zeiten sehen gut aus so
geschwindigkeiten die sehen auch gut aus
okay dann höher für mich look for the
distance vor der future ja rief die
mittels der trucker darf weiter fahren
um 105 euro leichter medien ist am
ersten tag vom münsterland nach
regensburg gekommen
die nacht hat sie auf einem autohof
verbracht in ihrem lkw
dieser wird während der arbeitswoche zu
ihrer wohnung mit bett schrank fächern
und sogar einem kühlschrank auf knapp 4
quadratmetern in ihrem schwarz ich will
ihn sicher hat keine angst auf einem
dunklen parkplatz zu übernachten noch
wohl lkw fahrer immer wieder opfer von
einbrüchen werden
[Musik]
von peter marx autoren und guckt ob
alles in ordnung ist ob sich solche noch
alle dran ist eine politische gruppe auf
die reihe finden und auf die radmuttern
welche beschädigungen sind manchmal
kriegt man das ja gar nicht so mit
manchmal sind es aber nicht langfinger
sondern wie wir ins kollegen die für ein
böses erwachen sorgen
damit war mein kollege hier in der
schweiz das duschen gegangen essen
gegangen kam wieder und dann sah das so
aus also die minister eindeutig jemand
rein gefahren
ohne irgendwie bescheid zu sagen ohne in
wien zettel da zu lassen oder irgendwie
was der ist halt einfach abgehauen
sowas kann man natürlich super super gut
gebrauchen also nicht wie wir ihn
beginnt ein langer tag bis zu 10 stunden
sitzt sie am steuer
dazu kommen die tätigkeiten beim be und
entladen und ihre arbeitszeit beträgt
dann mitunter 15 stunden
ein knochenjob und doch gibt es momente
in denen die berühmte trucker romantik
aufkommt
[Musik]
wenn man in der nacht die kasseler berge
fährt zum beispiel man auf dieses
lichtermeer unter schauen kann
neben traumhaften sonnenaufgängen hat
das frühe aufstehen einem weiteren
positiven nebeneffekt freie straßen
libyens start in die woche verläuft
reibungslos
ihr plan geht auf sie ist die erste an
der rampe
[Applaus]
angemeldet rampe bekommen abgeladen
leergut geladen papiere bekommen
doch wird wie wir noch weiter ohne
probleme durchkommen
gysi hat schüttorf nahe der
niederländischen grenze erreicht jetzt
muss die drei tonnen schwere maschine
von seinem auflieger runter geholt
werden
solche aktionen können sich hinziehen
sie hat das schon öfter mitgemacht große
verzögerungen kann er sich nicht leisten
die nächsten aufträge warten schon
jetzt werden wir ebenso runter kriegen
das maschinchen weil es ist nur eine
kleine und wir dann anfangen müssen hier
zu improvisieren
die tonnenschwere maschine soll nicht
mit einem kran sondern einem
gabelstapler vom auflieger gehoben
werden
ob das gut geht wenn die maschine kippt
kann es gefährlich werden für mensch und
material
doch sie ist wie immer die ruhe selbst
sollte das kein problem sein
platz genug
ich hatte erst gedacht das geht nach
hinten los und wir müssen kran bestellen
aber ging gut
während easy aufatmen kann läuft es für
pete deutlich schlechter pitt hat seinen
ablade termin verpasst
jetzt sind andere lkw folien dran und
das bedeutet warten auf unbestimmte zeit
wenn ich jetzt was weiß ich drei stunden
warten muss oder sowas mit abladen dann
habe ich nachher mit einer ladestation
probleme ich weiß nicht wie lange ich
meine mülleimer laden kann nachher in
hahn
jetzt ist keys disponent gefordert eine
lösung zu finden
es hätte so ein schöner tag sein können
jetzt stehe ich hier rum sind die können
sie nicht entscheiden und dann hast du
die ware drauf bringen weil ihm 15
paletten von holland hierhin ja genau
man sieht
man man man
nach ewiger wartezeit endlich ein anruf
super league tor sprechen
ja großes kino
jetzt hab ich na dachser dortmund fahren
und die scheiße dahin bringen
genau danach riss hahn darin mit dem
mülheimer ist auch gestorben
ja wir sehen wir mal weiter erläutert
irgendwann mal runter haben
dass meine kappe so was
bild darf nach drei stunden wartezeit
und verrichteter dinge vom hof fahren
die geladenen papiertücher müssen jetzt
von essen nach dortmund
zu allem überfluss im berufsverkehr
schaut sich 19 minuten verzögerung läuft
führt kommt es ganz dick stau ein unfall
voraus und beim verhalten der anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer platzt ihm der kragen
[Musik]
warum sich das jetzt noch mal angucken
der ist jetzt dadurch dass der eventuell
von hinten noch welche kommen könnten
gleich oder was soll scheint die
überhaupt nichts zu riskieren dass man
sich angucken die ziehen sofort wieder
rüber statt die rettungsgasse
beizubehalten
das nennen die einfache deutschland das
ist unglaublich aufregend ist bedient
nach einer stunde hatte er es endlich
geschafft zumindest bis zur nächsten
warte zone
[Applaus]
vivien sitzt seit fast neun stunden
hinterm steuer dafür alle nur
ausnahmsweise zehn stunden fahren
diese extra lange lenkzeit bewahrt sie
sich gerne für das ende der woche auf
wenn sie nach hause fahren will
sie muss jetzt einen parkplatz suchen
doch dann das
märz auf jeden fall ein bisschen ändern
kann man zwar nicht aber jetzt gerade
jetzt wenn es nicht mehr schaffen jetzt
muss ich meine zähne längste anreise 44
auf eine fünf stunden platz zu finden
ist natürlich also es ist ein dilemma
für vivien und sämtliche fahrer kollegen
je später der tag desto schwieriger wird
die parkplatzsuche jeden nachmittag
beginnt dann der kampf um die parkplätze
entlang der autobahn so auch an der a1
südlich von hamburg auf dem autohof
gerade ist hausmeister und platzwart
christian wohlers herr über 100 lkw
stellplätze an jedem späten nachmittag
beginnt der ansturm der brummifahrer
[Musik]
recht entspannen da kann man sich
vorstellen dass ins stocken der ganze
platz bis oben hin voll ist
also wir stehen in der längsrichtung
hier sind ja die parkbuchten und die
ganzen längsrichtung stehende noch lkws
an den seiten stehen sie überall und
jeder fahrer sind natürlich händeringend
parkplatz war seine lenkzeiten um müssen
sie ist früh dran und der lehre autohof
lässt sein sciacca herz höher schlagen
dass sie perfekt
ich musste mich ganz vorne stehen weil
ganz vorne gibt und dann meist noch mal
probleme mit den ein- und ausfahrten was
ich dann auch noch wehren so hinstellen
dass man kommen auf ein haus kommt das
meine ich das ist nicht mein ding sagt
glas gefunden
so steht er wenn die trucker feierabend
haben geht die arbeit für simone behrens
und ihre kolleginnen vom autohof
restaurant erst richtig los auch simone
hat diesel im blut das kommt nicht von
ungefähr
[Musik]
mein bruder fährt auch und ja es ist so
ein bisschen vielleicht auch laster das
pflaster diesel im blut oder wie man das
auch wie das immer so schön heißt also
es ist einfach so ich müsste auch nicht
noch mit auch nichts anderes machen
jetzt irgendwie geht bis ich irgendwann
im rollator sie kommt gerne auf diesen
autohof viele andere sind ihnen zu
anonymen
[Musik]
und natürlich du weißt du doch immer
aber du kommst mal vorbei das ist schon
was feines mitgebracht
[Musik]
die reale nur ein ziel wir wollen hier
in 5er abend verbringen gar nicht sagen
gar nichts hören gar nicht sehen wie man
so schön sagt
und wenn man dann so dicht entgegen
kommen und auch einfach das blinde die
ruhe die zeit die du brauchst wenn das
ist scheiße wir kommen denn schon
[Musik]
während gysi sein wohlverdientes
feierabend-bier genießt wird draußen um
die letzten freien parkplätze gefeilscht
jetzt ist platzwart christian gefragt er
entscheidet wo die lkw zu stehen haben
ich habe jetzt gerade hier geladen und
jetzt ist feierabend ich hab noch ich
kann noch zehn minuten und dann das ende
wer jetzt sagt geht nicht da muss ich
mir was einfallen lassen wenn man
nachmittags ab 3 uhr nick anfängt park
wird zu suchen haben verloren weil ich
bin um 3 uhr hier vorbeigefahren war
noch leer
dann habe ich geladene vorne jetzt bin
ich hier alles voll dass innerhalb von
zwei stunden
der lkw des truckers steht mitten auf
der fahrspur christian würde das
durchgehen lassen allerdings versperrt
das heck eines autotransporters die
durchfahrt für andere fahrzeuge
die beiden haben glück der fahrer ist
anwesend und macht die bahn frei
[Applaus]
ihr habt es geschafft ich habe etwas
gefunden doch für christian lauert auch
vor dem parkplatz ungemach nadel unser
nadelöhr hier ist absolutes halteverbot
wenn wir jetzt noch einen lkw dazu
kommen sollte sich da auch noch neben
wien stellt dann kommen die ersten
kleinfeld nicht weg und auch von der von
der ausfahrt erzähle ich ganz schwer da
kommt einer von vorne an von hier einer
von da und dann ist das ruckzuck ist
hier feierabend
doch was sollen wir machen ich könnte
jetzt alle weg und suchen habe ich sie
alle weg gehe ich rein und wieder raus
stehen drei neue also dagegen ihr
liebesleben also jeder das auch
international bekannt dass das zeigen
eigentlich absolutes halteverbot
heute
es ist doch noch klappt auch eine seite
da die kurven wir nun ganz kurzen wir
uns kurz und hast du ja
positiv waren
[Applaus]
aber kann die leute leicht glücklich
machen wenn sie am tag was zu kriegen
weil die haben alle wie gesagt die zeit
im nacken
das ist das schwierige bei jedem das ist
mal wieder dasselbe spiel die müssen
halten sonst trafen auf der a2 hat ein
weiterer brummifahrer den
vorgeschriebenen mindestabstand
unterschritten
die lkw spezialisten der
polizeidirektion hannover holen ihn von
der autobahn während
polizeioberkommissar sascha möbius sein
hauptaugenmerk auf die fahrtenschreiber
manipulation wirft kümmert sich polizei
kommissar volkers kerker um die
ladungssicherheit und den zustand der
fahrzeuge
wenn ich mir jetzt diesen technischen
ausdruck anschaut der ist relativ lang
daran sich halt auch schon dass der lkw
nicht mehr der neueste ist der ist jetzt
zum beispiel auch 2009 das ist für jetzt
wenn ein lkw im güterverkehr schunk
entscheidern volker skerka wird schnell
fündig einen reifen ist beschädigt gut
wenn ich mir das jetzt anschaue also
irgendwie hat diesen reifen zum beispiel
x markiert weil jemand tiefen einschnitt
da müsste jetzt gleich mal schauen wie
tief das ist das sind natürlich schon
menge wo man überlegen muss ob man ihm
die weiterfahrt untersagt doch den
polnischen fahrer bleibt ein verbot
erspart
er hat halt nicht viel geladen hat eine
list accent man das ganze die kann er
hochfahren und dementsprechend der sich
nicht traut kann er sich auch nicht
weiter irgendwie negativ auswirkungen
wenn er natürlich das fahrzeug auswählen
mit 23 tonnen
und ja direkt herunter lässt dann hätte
ich ihn so nicht weiter verlassen mängel
an fahrzeugen und fehlverhalten der
fahrer sind nicht selten folgen von
lohndumping im europaweiten
logistikgeschäft jetzt sind wir gerade
bei meinem nächsten phase die polen
verdienen immer besser und jetzt hat man
ganz hobby auf polnischen lkw schon
bulgarische fahrer also es geht jetzt
immer eine woche nach hinten und damit
die fahrer möglichst lange fahren können
damit sie dem und in den viel geld
reinbringen und bei
lenkzeitüberschreitungen oder ruhezeit
verstößen nicht auffallen gegengerade
die osteuropäer in die technische
manipulation über die neueste art der
manipulation ist die sogenannte muslim
eine produktion da wird ein usb artiges
gerät ins bordnetz gestöpselt dass er
kennt den fahrtenschreiber und wenn der
gesteckt ist dann wird ruhe zeit
aufgezeichnet obwohl das fahrzeug fährt
das ist doch sehr sehr schwer
nachzuweisen das ist das neueste
bei pid geht es weiter mit dem teufel zu
auch in dortmund wird er seine ware nach
einer stunde wartezeit nicht los
ob es jetzt essen war oder jetzt
dortmund also das ist einfach nur keine
gelaufen
jetzt hat man sich darauf geeinigt dass
die ware mit ton sagen platz nehmen und
über uns in die halle kommt und zu allem
überfluss fahren wir dann jetzt
natürlich erst mal wieder im stau weil
wir wollen ja auch noch gar nicht nach
hause
ein folgeauftrag gehen ich hätte laden
wollen den haaren ist auch weggefallen
das weiß ich jetzt nicht auf einer von
meinen kollegen übernommen hat wenn
nicht ist da auch noch ein großer
geldverlust ja davon daher ist der tag x
richtig blöd gelaufen nicht nur für mich
auch für die firma würde ich behaupten
libyen hat nach drei and ladestationen
in bayern wörth an der isar erreicht
nach 10 stunden hinterm steuer sehnt sie
sich nach einer erfrischenden dusche
wer seinen alltag auf autohöfen
verbringen muss darf nicht zimperlich
sein
manchmal tauchen patrick löcher dabei da
machst du nicht mal mehr mit mit
badelatschen reingehen aber sonst
passiert eigentlich immer
[Musik]
ich habe keine freie stellen danke diese
nasszelle ist nicht nur sauber
sie verfügt auch über eine
sonderausstattung die medien begeistert
[Musik]
aber ich bin einfach cool dass dir das
hier allgemein auch anbieten
das hat man nicht so oft wie wir ist
mutter eines dreijährigen sohnes der
unter der woche bei seinem vater oder
williams eltern ist jeden abend ruft sie
zu hause an um nach dem rechten zu hören
heute erreicht sie niemanden die woche
auf ihn auf für mich ist da sind wir
ganz schön wenn wir abends oder zum
feierabend hinter mal telefonieren da
kann ich ihn sehen sie dass es ihm gut
geht dann ist das auf jeden fall das
gefühl der fahrer job kann einsam sein
und beschwerlich fernab vom eigenen
zuhause
[Musik]